Each organization should determine it's own severity classification, based on
its release and artifact peculiarities and whatever source issue tracking system
or source control system that they have. Here's one possible schema.
It includes three different levels. The least severe is that minor re,
rework is required. That this rework can be verified by the author.
This would be the case if there were questions about the comments or
standards conformance, something like that. A somewhat more severe level would
be where there's conditional rework that it would be verified by the moderator.
And then, for major rework situations, reinspection is required. And here
a guideline would be that if greater than 20% of the document or 20 hours of
work or 100 lines of code have been affected then a rereview might be required.